now this year's Super Bowl will be
history in the making because For the
First Time Ever the pregame flyover will
be piloted by an all-female crew
croissant cleat reports
[Music]
racing Skyward we're flying with
Lieutenant Peggy Dente as she gets ready
for Super Bowl Sunday when she'll be
buzzing State Farm Stadium right after
the national anthem have you done a
flyover before I have not no that's my
first one small stage for a first
flyover yeah no pressure nervous you
know I think it'd be crazy if you
weren't a little bit nervous but a
little bit of nerves keeps you honest
keeps you humble keeps you focused on
the mission the four fighter flyover
will be an all-woman team of seven as
the Navy celebrates 50 years of female
pilots in 1973 eight women were the
first allowed to enter flight school six
winner in their wings today women make
up about 15 percent of Navy Pilots women
aviators have taught the Navy that women
can do anything that they set their
minds to you know there's nothing that
women aren't capable of Dante fell in
love with Aviation as a kid flying with
her dad her grandfather flew helicopters
in Vietnam inspiring her to join the
Navy foreign
Growler can fly plenty fast and upside
down on Sunday it'll be flying low and
slow we're all wing women here A Team
showing the world how women roll
Chris Van Cleave CBS News Luke Air Force
Base Arizona
and history will be made in more ways
than one it'll be the first time in the
Super Bowl we'll hop two black starting
quarterbacks Patrick Mahomes of the
Chiefs and the Eagles Jalen hurts are
also the youngest pair of starting QBs
in Super Bowl history